a live look now at the white house where
cuban americans are rallying to demand
action from the biden administration
against the communist regime
dan bonginos the host of unfiltered and
canceled in the usa on fox nation right
now
dan are you surprised this opening for
the president united
states that he's choosing not to run
through it a chance for the first time
in
50 years to get a the communist regime
out of cuba
brian this is the biggest bunt
in american political history it's a
bunt
not the cake like my big fat greek
wedding a bun
a bunt like a baseball bat the cuban
government
kills and tortures people has
impoverished this great nation of people
down there just
you know 90 miles from key west right
and
tortured them beaten them politically
imprisoned them for decades
you finally have again some semblance of
a freedom movement people speak out
and what do you hear from the white
house it took them what
five days to say hey you know political
torture
beatings communism death and destruction
maybe that's a bad idea five days it
took you
five days and then the democrats brian
outside of the white house
you've had other democrats who lie for
the cuban regime
oh it's just due to the embargo they're
protesting the embargo they are
because i speak a little spanish it's
not great but it looks nice
they're saying libertad which i'm
reasonably kind i got my
podcast he speaks spanish that that's
liberty right gee
yeah yeah he speaks about it that means
liberty they're right here
he can translate they're not saying you
know we need more
food we need medicine although they do
they're saying liberty
right and you know one more thing hold
on i know but one more thing the reason
aoc and others
aren't speaking out here and saying it
and lying about what they're saying
liberty
is because they are socialists they love
socialism
it's as simple as that don't over
complicate it it's as simple as that
and remember their obama policy was
reapproachment they wanted to engage
and the people that were in charge of
that policy are in the policy uh
the policy department leading the charge
on cuba and the bite administration this
guy juan gonzalez and emily
mandrella and she is therefore
engagement so they don't know what to do
right now but listen to this dan
imagine if cuba had a had a
representative government
and think about what they're doing in
venezuela think about what they're doing
in bolivia
and they look at the unsavory acts and
the fact it is a
outlet for china uh and for russia
all that would be gone that's an
opportunity you think he'd run through
but let's pivot let's pivot to hunter
biden
turns out even cnn has a problem with
this rookie artist
and not and meeting with potential
buyers that could be paying him
up to five hundred thousand dollars
listen
i find it hard to believe that there is
any such thing as a blind sale when
you're purchasing art
from the president's son democrats are
in this conundrum of trying to
say defend what hunter biden is doing
when they've spent the past few years
very much criticizing former president
trump this is a huge optics problem an
ethics problem
they see a problem the obama
administration saw a problem when he was
with bharisma
is he trolling us is hunter trolling us
or his dad
they have to be they really have to be
laughing at us they have to be sitting
in the movie theater in the white house
going you know guys there's grifting and
then there's grifting
and look at these idiots like look at
look how we suckered these american
people
that's a good quest you know i gotta
tell you i didn't really think about it
that way brian before the segment but i
think you're onto something
i think they are trolling us they have
to be openly mocking us
seriously if there was like a major
league baseball of grifting
this guy's the mvp of the league i mean
talk about a grifter and you
you wonder to yourself did they think
this thing through like if i'm china
right now
i get some ccp associated wealthy
businessman
to overpay for a painting i then leak it
to the american media
and cause like a geopolitical incident
but of course because the biden family
is too stupid to figure that out
or they're trolling us you may be right
they just don't seem to care
they're either too dumb or they're
laughing at us absolutely dan and uh
it's i think it's really important to uh
to understand this is
uh just the beginning and by the way
wendy sherman the number two diplomat
it just got berated in china overnight
uh and uh right she's representing our
country so that's really going
on dan we're going to listen to your
radio show from 12 to 3 today
uh and not only that we're going to
watch it on fox nation so we can do both
that'll be great right after your show
thanks buddy absolutely
all right dan pontino thanks so much